foreign
hello my name is Paul Mooney and I am a
developer relations engineer on the
cattle team
in September 2022 we conducted kaggle's
sixth annual industry-wide survey an
attempt to surface a truly comprehensive
view of the state of data science and
machine learning
we received nearly 24
000 respondents from 173 different
countries
and we ask them lots of questions about
their backgrounds preferred Technologies
and machine learning techniques
if you're not already familiar with
kaggle or the world's largest data
science community
there are over 10 million machine
learning engineers and data scientists
on our platform
and we provide them with an environment
to share resources and knowledge with
each other every year we release the
surveys de-identified data and we run a
competition rewarding the best public
analysis
you can download everything and find
this year's analytics competition at
kaggle.com
kaggle survey2022.
today since we're at Google next this
presentation is focused on the nearly 2
000 respondents that currently have the
job title data scientist
I'll be presenting a few key findings
covering four areas of Interest
demographics programming machine
learning and cloud computing
throughout the presentation we'll also
be hearing from several guest panelists
to share more insights from their
perspective
our panelists are Siobhan Bonsall 3x
kaggle Grandmaster senior data scientist
at h2o.ai and a member of the first
place team from last year's survey
analytics competition
and drata El taglio Taco Grandmaster
data scientist and endava and a member
of the second place team from last
year's survey analytics competition
and Kaz Sato a staff developer Advocate
at Google Cloud
and from the kaggle team we have Nate
Keating the head of product at caco
and Walter Reed a data scientist on the
kaggle team helps to run our machine
learning competitions thank you all so
much for joining us
now let's get started
one particularly consistent finding from
our survey is that the data science
Industry is highly gender imbalanced
with women consistently making up less
than 15 percent of all survey
respondents that have the job title of
data scientists
this has been the case every year for
the past six years
we've seen much more rapid change taking
place in terms of the locations that
data scientists are doing their work
though
the USA has always been a center for
data scientists but but we have been
seeing a consistently increasing number
of professional data scientists living
and working out of Indian Japan over the
past six years
uh specifically we've seen approximately
a 3X increase in the proportion of data
scientists from India and approximately
a 4X increase in the proportion of data
scientists from Japan since the year
2017.
a few questions for our panel
do you have any insights on the growth
of data science as a career in specific
geographic regions
are there any unique Dynamics or
initiatives that accelerate growth
one Insight that I have seen is when
there are some popular individuals some
Personalities in data science data
science professionals from a particular
region then next generation or the
Juniors tend to follow them they tend to
aim to become such individuals in their
Journey as well that's that's leads to a
personal curiosity to become a better
data scientist and this has this has
been some of the reasons that have led
to more growth more curiosity in data
science systems in the communities the
most important driver for the the
Congress in Japan that expands the
activities and the Committees rapidly in
Japan and uh there are thousands of
people in the cargo ja black Channel
where people are chatting and sharing
the narratings and each other uh day by
day and uh
and also the subcargillers published a
book in Japanese how to win the
competition in Chicago or what is
Chicago how to get started in Chicago so
those are the active the activities by
the community people has been driving
the Iraq growth
what I've seen and I'm actually very
happy about is I think I've spoken with
two companies in the past month
and these are two very different
companies from uh one is based in U.S
one is based in India and they've been
around for around 10 15 years let's say
and they are both looking to create so
they aren't growing they're actually
right now starting to create their data
science teams because they are seeing
potential and they are trying to
catch the market let's say and the
Giants and creating data science teams
and it's absolutely incredible they are
looking into Automation and optimization
and they realize well data science is uh
the thing to do and I see like great
great potential of many more companies
doing that in the near future if they
are not already
more than 95 percent of kaggle data
scientists report using the Python
programming language on a regular basis
Python and SQL Remain the two most
common programming languages for data
scientists although interestingly we're
seeing smaller and smaller fractions of
survey respondents reporting back that
they're doing their work using r
upert notebooks are the most common
development environment for kaggle data
scientists
but vist code has been increasing in
popularity over recent years
perhaps due to its ever improving
support for notebooks itself
again we see a decrease in the
proportion of survey respondents
reporting that they are using our studio
whereas support for pycharm has been
quite consistent
collab notebooks are a no cost Jupiter
notebook like environment that provides
access to Virtual compute
and the majority of data scientists now
report that they use this product on a
regular basis
it's notable that adoption of collab has
increased so steadily year after year
we've reported usage exceeding that of
kaggle's own zero cost notebook editor
even amongst a survey of the kaggle
community
and now some questions for our panel
just a shift towards vs code and Jupiter
notebooks reflect a trend towards
choosing Ides that have the option of
being hosted within a web browser
what do you think drives People's Choice
of IDE
why would users be shifting away from
desktop apps
so I started machine learning data
science about 10 years ago and I think
my my workstation my computer at home I
had four gigabytes of RAM which was
which was barely enough to do anything
and I was I remember being stuck on this
like every two years around Christmas I
would upgrade you know I'd upgrade my
Ram and then I'd upgrade my hard drive
and I'd upgrade my CPU and then after a
while right the the once there was a
decent cloud computing it kind of didn't
make sense to do that anymore so
literally there is nothing I do in terms
of data science that I do on like a
local physical machine anymore I thought
about it I thought about upgrading into
a powerful workstation but uh cloud is
so good is so accessible that it just
doesn't make sense
so it really does I I think this growth
or this trend is just because it makes
so much sense to be platform agnostic
you know do your work in the browser it
doesn't matter if you're logging in from
your Mac from your Chromebook from your
PC uh while you're on the road uh you
have basically everything you need
um you know uh accessible to you you
know and that's one of the great things
about the um you know the online
notebooks right the the platforms that
have compute uh obviously kaggle is a
great example where
um you know we we've known people that
have done phenomenal work while they're
sitting on a laptop at the side of a
pool watching their kids swim okay so it
doesn't make sense to try to do that on
your laptop when uh when you can do it
in the cloud
there are multiple reasons why there is
a more focused uh shift is happening on
non-destop apps more browser-based apps
well first and Prime reason is more
accessibility and portability the
ability to write programs and codes
anywhere in the world as as long as
there is an internet connection that
really helps individuals to like quickly
write their programs and code assets
then the next important point is there
is no hassle in setup configuration OS
related dependencies or any installation
issues as such they get a ready to use
environment where they can immediately
start working on their projects that
leads to a better experience and
browser-based IDs definitely provide a
much better user experience a rich user
experience and it can be tailored it can
be customized to their requirements
their need as such and last but not the
least is about collaboration many
browser-based IDs have made need
collaboration simpler and easier be it
say collaborating your projects and
codes with other team members or it may
be collaborative shared resources if
there is a programmer who has maybe
ideal resources they may can they can
share it with their team members so that
all the team members can make the best
out of it there's a lot of reasons why I
think many things in general are moving
to a web-based model
um and I think these are all relevant
for
uh the popularity of fiasco and Jupiter
notebooks and a few other Ides but I
also think
um they have some unique benefits that
are not necessarily related to
um to being web-based so a vs code for
instance is free it's important uh it's
a built on open source which is another
large Trend over the last decade and I
think it really nailed the customization
or the customizability of its extension
model
um better than a lot of uh similar IDs
had
um and it also you know piggybacked on
this new web development space where
some languages had dominant Ides for
Java or or python for instance but the
kind of new stack typescript HTML CSS
all rolled together
um node.js uh you know from a decade or
so ago didn't necessarily have a home so
the multi-language support for the kind
of new stack of web dev was one of the
big things that helped BS code
um really take off and then the Jupiter
notebooks I think it comes down to the
interactivity in addition to all the
things I mentioned above
um for data workloads just being able to
quickly prototype and have that
interactivity with
um with the data you're working with is
just super important so
um being able to prototype and iterate
quickly
um is something that I think just just
lent itself really really well to being
a data professional
for adoption of Open Source machine
learning Frameworks
we've been really impressed with the
year-over-year growth from pie torch and
the pi torch ecosystem
compared to say the more steady and
consistent adoption that we've seen for
tensorflow
interestingly we observe that gradient
boosting Frameworks such as XG boost and
light GBM are extremely popular with
kaggle data Sciences
the ever popular psychic learn framework
Remains the most commonly used machine
learning framework
perhaps because of its sheer utility
and also just the usefulness the
Frameworks like XG boost and
scikit-learn for working with tabular
data which is always just so common
Transformer architectures are becoming
more and more popular for deep learning
models
it's great to see how these
architectures have proved useful outside
of domains such as natural language
processing where they were first found
to be useful
data scientists today are using
transformer-based model architecture for
computer vision applications too
now some questions for our panel
she suppose the popularity of
scikit-learn is attributable to its
ability to cover so many use cases
versus say a more narrow framework
can you speak to the differences in
which Frameworks are best used for which
applications
how fundamental is tabular data in
business
do you see a clear winner in the boosted
trees versus tabular neural network
space
wire boosted trees so dominant on Kegel
um the importance of tabular data so in
many Industries especially Insurance
banking Finance tabular data is still at
a code of many high value business use
cases or business value as such many
business driven decisions are still made
on tabular data sets and that's why even
techniques like ingredient boosting or
XT boost type of models are popular the
reason is that because boosted trees
tend to outperform any on any structured
data or tabular data problems though
tabular neural networks have shown a
very good Improvement in performance but
still boosted trees has been part of
many success stories essentially on
tablet data well there are multiple
reasons for it one reason is
um in many tabular data problems one of
the goal is to estimate the decision
boundary uh or identify the objective
function and that's where boosted trees
perform really well in estimating that
while neural network sometimes struggle
in identifying the best fit function
the other reason is that when when we
increase the feature complexity space
when we keep on adding more and more
features boosted trees work on the
fundamental idea of Information Gain
they they are robust to more complex
features even if there are many
uninformatic features in your data set
they still have learned the ability to
disregard the less important features
while on the other hand neural network
tend to struggle neural network tend to
degrade the performance if the
complexity of the future space is added
as such
and one more reason why Tableau Data and
boosted trees shows a good combination
that's not on the lines of accuracy and
performance but rather on explainability
when it again comes to high value use
cases
um in and in many regulated Industries
as well explainability is very important
and that's where boosted trees are more
explainable
um that's why they are more adopted and
because of the same reasons uh XT boost
like GBM and other boosted trees shows a
good uh dominance on kaggle as well I
think I want to hit at least a couple of
these first socket learn I absolutely
love scikit-learn it is a case study in
how to do things right
um suck it learn packs so many different
useful functionalities regardless of of
what you're modeling and things like
metrics things like model selection
cross validation splitting hyper
parameter optimization so socket learned
is all of that
um you know for the work that I do and I
touch all sorts of different data sets I
touch all sorts of different uh file
types um always like scikit-learn is
always getting loaded into into my
workflow
um the other thing that they've done
really really well is avoided the flavor
of the day so it does a ton of stuff but
it's not bloated with all sorts of
things that just aren't useful and go
out of favor so I think that's a a
really important key and then
um I would say scikit-learn also has
done a really good job of having a
consistent API
so you you know brand new function
within scikit-learn you already know how
to how to call it because you know the
API the methods are you know very very
similar in fact right they've driven
across the industry so many other
libraries uh really work to uh align to
that because it's so dominant
so you know there's there's literally
almost always a library that does a
specific thing better than scikit-learn
but psychic learn gets you 80 or 80 90
of the way there and then you know for
whatever reason you want to go that
other 10 then you can do a specialized
library but um yeah they've done a great
job in kudos to all the the maintainers
and the contributors to scikit-learn
now the question about boosted trees so
that's a really interesting question
um I you know
there's usually not a right answer that
the the answer is depends on what you
want to do if you want a really simple
explainable model boost the trees might
be Overkill you might just want like a
simple logistic regression where you can
look at the the parameters but in terms
of the balance between speed
practicality
um and uh accuracy boost the trees again
and again and again it's just
you know proven itself
um
in terms of doing some of the more
advanced things like tabular neural
networks um yeah absolutely I I think
right there's some great work that's
shown you can get lift when you go to
the more complex but it's it you know
it's going to cost you in terms of
training you get to have Hardware
um so the extra incremental Improvement
uh needs the the the benefit of the
extra incremental Improvement has to
justify the cost so again it's never
like it's there are some people say it's
always XD boost it's right it's almost
always but it really does depend on what
you're trying to do in my opinion
whenever you are beginning to do data
science your first interaction within
the machine learning realm would be
psychic learn because you are using this
in every step along the way from
splitting pre-processing doing the
actual machine learning and then even
going into model explainability and bias
and so on so psychic learn kind of
covers everything and it's extremely
usable
um for a beginner and also for an
intermediate or or an advanced data
scientist I believe or at least on Kegel
the popularity of busy trees is drawn by
boyan talking I think every day on
Twitter about busty trees so there might
be a reason there there is super hype
around them but uh besides besides that
in my experience whenever I use on
tabular data booster cheese versus an
end booster is always
um
yield better results
there is also the fact that they are
extremely easy to use many many people
have used them in the past so there is a
bunch of documentation and examples so
if you are trying to do something
chances are there are like a bunch of
other projects that you can Inspire
yourself and draw ideas from them and
create your own project so this is a
very very good part to it's extremely
easy to tune and there is also the fact
that
um
rather than an ends have being like a
little bit of a black box and going to
business and be like oh I did a
prediction but I cannot really explain
why uh busy trees have modern
explainability in the back so you can
kind of Trace back how they are thinking
and usually whatever there is a project
people also want to understand why the
model predicted a certain number or
certain class and so on and you have
that with [ __ ] trees as well
Amazon web services Remains the most
popular cloud provider but we've seen
really strong growth from all three of
the major Cloud providers
Amazon web services saw their share grow
by 11.9 percent last year
Google Cloud platform by 23 percent
and Microsoft Azure grew by 7.8 percent
since last year in terms of adoption
by the kaggle data scientists
specialized Hardware such as tensor
processing units or tpus appear to be
gaining some initial traction with caco
data scientists these types of chips are
specifically designed to accelerate
common data science workflows
and we'd love to see how much innovation
has been happening in this space
and now our final questions for our
panel
can you share how users make choices in
selecting between various Cloud
providers
what do you think is driving the growth
of accelerators are there projects
better suited for these more specialized
processors
make a selection on your kind of large
Cloud providers are really big choice I
think it all depends on scale but in
general the users themselves which I
think is what the question is asking
aren't always the ones making this this
choice but rather it's an organization
as a whole that that's choosing a cloud
provider so it's a really big decision
it tends to come out of lots of long
meetings lots of long requirements
Gathering a detailed assessment and
Technical evaluation of all the various
platforms but in many ways you're
looking for a strategic partner it's
going to be one of the the biggest
choices technology choices certainly
that a company makes in the modern world
and so you're looking for a team that
you can sit down and work with and who
you know has the Deep expertise
technology understanding of the
processes uh that that you need to
deliver your business to your to your
customers or users and so in the data
science and AI space I think it comes
down a lot to their experience at doing
data science and AI at scale and in
production do they have the the software
both
um kind of the infrastructure and maybe
managed services to work with data to uh
to make doing machine learning and
production as easy as possible and when
you sit across the table from them as a
as a CIO or a VP of of data science or
something like that do you feel like
this is a partner that you can work with
who's going to help understand your
problems is going to help deliver you
know Solutions and technology that
enables your business to to achieve its
strategic goals so I I have been hearing
from the many data scientists and the
Machine learning Engineers that India
real world problems are going to be data
science or machine writing AI
uh sometimes the dataway has to be a
bottleneck because you always have to
try out many different feature
engineering or pre-processing with the
data cells uh the most ability all the
data coming from the data warehouse for
storage so they end up with struggling
on extracting and data from data
warehouse and if your data warehouse law
uh the all the entire the process for
data in the analytics stacks Bitcoin is
the uh the very fast and scalable data
in your house because it is specially
designed for the scalability and
performance it is a fully managed
serverless data warehouse so every time
you run an SQL query on bigquery that
will be processed with just thousands of
different CPUs and the hundreds of the
SSD ssds running in power only for a
single query still because it's super
inexpensive and we can do that because
the Google Cloud itself is designed to
work as a data science as a computer
meaning designed for massively power
processing processing from the start or
from the networking devices or for from
the middlewares the softwares for the
communication so that reason why you can
easily uh run the single query running
on this thousand CPS in a few seconds
this is actually one reason
and the the answers for the second
questions uh it's all about the end of
the movers low okay as we have seen in
the past few more throw putting the
performance of the CPUs and GPU rapidly
when I started working on this the the
programming give us like a four
megahertz now it's a four gigahertz of
the CPU clock but we are not seeing the
increase of TCP clock anymore because
the moves rods is ending as stated by
the CEO of any video recently
so the all the cloud Windows uh
now um trying to solve this problem by
designing a specialized Hardware so
processes that is so-called domain
specific activity or DSA and Google has
been working on the DSA for many years
and one of them is GTP utensil process
unit TPU is much efficient especially
power efficient that is
that the generalized processes such as
the CPU user GPU because GTP is designed
for running a large scale mathematics of
Matrix operations uh in efficient way
so every time you use EFTPS you set the
uh the powers that takes the cost for
the each training so that's the reason
why the tpus and the accelerometers as a
super
uh the attractive option for the
characters as well
and with that that concludes our short
presentation
as mentioned earlier we've made the data
public along with past year survey data
and we invite anyone and everyone to
come and explore it
don't forget to submit your analysis for
consideration in our thirty thousand
dollar storytelling competition
thanks again to our panelists for
contributing and thank you all for
attending goodbye